hi thank you so I'm gonna talk about
exponential separation of information
and communication and basically anup
talked before about interactive coding
which is the interactive analog of
Shannon's noisy theorem or of error
correcting codes and this talk is more
about interactive compression which is
kind of the analog of Shannon noises
theorem or off man encoding so okay
suddenly present the topic okay by the
way this is joint work with ron ron ron
has who's here and I'm not gonna who is
a student it fights money okay so this
is a starting point of our paper we talk
about data compression what is that a
compression we're assuming that we have
two players Alice and Bob Alice knows
some string X chosing according to a
distribution that is known to both Alice
and Bob and she just want to send this
message the string X to Bob the
questions is how many bits does she need
to send to Bob so Bob will be able to
retrieve the message with high
probability and of course the answer
that was given by Shannon and and by
Hoffman is that we need Alice needs to
send H of X bits where H is the entropy
function ok so in general this H of X
may be smaller than the size of X you
don't always have to send the whole
message sometimes you can send less bits
and this is an amazing theorem of course
the data compression there it's it's an
amazing result and it basically tells
you that any message can be compressed
to its information content so if you
have a very long but uninformative
message you can shrink it down to its
actual information content this is a big
revolution this is amazing and we want
it to be amazing so we're considering
the interactive analog of this theorem
and it is called the interactive
compression problem and it was suggested
like a few years ago
and basically the setting now is kind of
the same we have Alice and Bob but
another they're engaging in some
conversation okay they talk to each
other before Alice just wanted to send
the sex to bottom but now Bob a reply to
the sex and Alice may reply back and so
on so we're suing the tulisan Bob engage
in some interactive communication
protocol and we ask the same question
can the protocols transcript be
compressed to its actual information
content ok so basically the same set is
the same question but in the interactive
setting where messages go back and forth
ok so next I want to kind of define this
question more formally and to do that
we'll use the setting of communication
complexity which I kind of assume we all
know so basically in communication
complexity we have our two guys Alice
and Bob Alice has some input X as before
but now we assume that Bob gets possibly
different input Y and the players want
to compute F of XY for some function f
that they both know so Alice knows one
part of the input and Bob knows another
part and they need to compute something
that a pen depends on both and the
question is how many bits do they need
to exchange so ok of course to solve it
to compute F they run some protocols
some communication protocol there
they're sending messages back and forth
and hopefully eventually they'll be able
to tell what f of X Y is and this
protocol is adaptive every message may
depend on the previous message sent so
this is communication complexity and for
the second a stock will will care about
distribution or communication complexity
so the distributional setting is the
same as in the previous slide but now we
assume that x and y are chosen according
to some publicly known distribution you
ok so x and y are sampled according to
some distribution mew that both Alice
and Bob know and we're assuming that the
players are allowed to use some
randomness
public or private they can toss some
coins and we only ask them to be able to
compute f of X Y with high permeability
over this distribution and randomness
okay so we on distribution of setting
means that there is an underlying
distribution inputs are sampled from
this distribution players may use
randomness and we allow them to air with
some small probability say one-third now
we can define the communication
complexity of a protocol to be the
maximum number of bits that the protocol
may exchange over all possible inputs so
i define hear it here is worst case you
can think about average case it wouldn't
change their result this is the worst
case length of the protocol require the
communication complexity of the protocol
and you can also define the
communication complexity of a function f
so if you have a function of the
communication complexity of f is kind of
the communication complexity of the best
protocol that computes f so you go over
all the protocol that computes f in this
sense right so you go over all the
protocol that computer and you look for
the one that minimizes the communication
so the cheapest one that still computes
f and this is the communication
complexity of a function okay so those
things are pretty standard but let me go
back to the question of interactive
compression and recall that the question
was whether the transcript of every
protocol can be compressed to its
information content this is our question
and of course in order to make it formal
we need to first know how were in how do
we intend to measure information content
of an interactive protocol so before in
the Shannon setting the way to measure
information was the entropy function so
we need some analog of the entropy
function for the interactive setting and
the measure that was suggested in
Newsday
in previous papers is this notion of an
information costs and information cost
is kind of a cool definition and it
seemed to be the right analog of entropy
for several reasons so next I want to
show you define what is information
costs okay so what is information costs
very roughly stating it it's the amount
of information players learned about
each other is input from the interaction
okay so how much information would Alice
learn about Bob's input and how much
information with Bob learn about Alice's
input okay so this is not a proper
definition this is a proper definition
and so this formula to find the
information cost of a protocol pie with
respect to a distribution mu and it uses
this i thinkI is the mutual information
it's a notion from information theory it
has a really simple definition and a
very intuitive meaning so even if you
don't know what mutual information is
don't worry it will be pretty clear and
anyway with the main thing I need is
this high-level intuition but let's read
the formula what what is the information
cost of a protocol pie ok so in this
formula we're using capital X capital y
and capital pie to denote random
variables x and y are just sampled from
you it's the random variables
representing the inputs and capital pi
is the transcript of little pie so if
you take this little pie the protocol
and you run it over the inputs capital x
and y you get that transcript the list
of messages we call it capital pie it's
a random variable ok so now we can
define the information cost of pie the
formula has two components two terms the
first one this one tried to measure the
amount of information that Alice learns
about why from pie they expected amount
right because those creatures deciding
is an expectation over n trapeze
and okay so basically all is ok so this
is what we're trying to measure how many
bits of information with Alice game
about why when she says pie and we
really test the mutual information
between PI and Y given X again this is
the amount of information that pie
reveals about why when you already know
X so Alice knows X to begin with we gave
her ex and we asked how many bits of
information can she learn from pie now
she sees the transcript how many bits of
information this transcript would give
her about Bob's input Y so this is the
first term it measures what is the
amount of information Alice gained and
we have a second term that is is the
same but for Bob this measures the
amount of information that Bob learns
about what about X from pie so Bob knows
why how many bits of information would
he learn from seeing pie about X this is
the definition questions about the
definition we wouldn't we want me the
exact formula will need this but if you
have questions please ok and as we've
done before now we can define the
information cost of a function and then
if the information cost of the fund of a
function is kind of the information cost
of the cheapest protocol that computes
the function over the measure so we're
going over all the protocols and we're
looking for one that minimizes the
information costs ok ok so this was just
the definitions but now we're in the fun
part we can actually see the question
and results so the question that we're
asking is really whether the
communication of every function is
roughly the information of the function
ok so we will find a measure of
communication the communication
complexity which is the number of bits
that the parties exchange
so this is just a number of bits and we
defined another notion information costs
which is the number of information bits
so this is the number of communication
bits and this is the number of
information bits and we can ask whether
it is always the case that the
communication requires to complete the
function over the measure is roughly the
same as the number of information bits
unit this is the question and you can
see that one direction is really easy so
this direction the communication is at
least the information because if ålesund
a bit too Bob the spit can possibly give
Bob more than one bit of factual
information about X ok I mean she can
give him the first bit of exit will give
him one bit of information she may give
him zero bits of information she may
send something that is independent of X
right but you can't possibly if she
sends one bit she can't give Bob more
than one bit of information in
expectation so every bit so this just
shows that every bit of the protocol of
any protocol cannot give the other party
more than one bit of information and
therefore for every protocol the
communication is at least the
information because every bit you sound
is one bit of communication and possibly
less than one bit of information and and
this shows that if you take minimum over
the two sides or infimum you can see
that for every function the
communication of the function is at
least the information of the function so
this is the easy direction and it kind
of makes sense I guess communication is
at least the information if you want to
say something you need to to at least
give this number of communication bits
ok and you know the more interesting
direction is the other direction can you
show that the communication is not much
larger than the information and this is
a real problem because
but we look this direction oh yeah I'm
you know I'm very bad with the direction
this is the right direction we want to
show that the communication is roughly
smaller it's a question can it be much
more oh yes the question is whether this
this direction is correct the answer
will be no okay but okay so this is kind
of the punchline that the answer is no
but but but okay so this was the
question can the coming the question is
whether or not the communication can be
much larger than the information and
what I'm claiming that we can choose the
argument we had in the previous slide
it's not true for every protocol so
there are protocols with communication
that there are with communication that
is much larger than the information so
right we can just send every bit 10
times you can send randomized it's not a
problem to waste bits soap I can be a
stupid and wasteful protocol we there is
nothing we can do about it but this
doesn't settle this direction we ask
whether for every function the
communication is roughly the information
and if you want to settle this direction
you really need to answer the
interactive compression problem this is
the problem we had in there in a
previous slides in the beginning but
this is a more formal statement so what
is the interactive compression
interactive the interactive compression
problem is the following suppose I'm
given a protocol pie he asked me whether
I can find another protocol pie prime
that simulates pie such that the
communication of pie prime is roughly
the information of pie ok so again it
may be the case that the communication
of pie is much larger than the
information of pie this is this was this
claim but if pies is you know a stupid
protocol that wastes bits then maybe you
can find another protocol pie prime that
is
stupid and not wasteful and for this spy
prime the communication will be roughly
the same as the information ok so again
the question is you're given a protocol
can you find in possibly different
protocol for which the communication of
the new protocol is roughly the
information of the original protocol
this is a question and to settle this
this direction you really need to answer
this question and this is the kind of
the interactive analog of half-man
encoding questions about the question ok
ok so by now we have several very clever
compression protocols by people in here
we'll we'll hear about this paper
tomorrow but the the thing that the work
that is the most relevant to our work is
this worked by brotherman and what Mark
shows is that you can always find a PI
prime such that the communication of pi
prime is at most 2 to the 0 of the
information cost of pie okay this is
good it gives us some bound on the
communication of the simulation protocol
but this bound is exponential okay and
this is the best guarantee in general we
we have but still the conclusion from
the previous slides is only that the
communication costs is sandwiched
between the information costs and to to
the information costs and prior to her
work there was no separation between
information and communication we really
didn't know whether this is always the
case that those two are like very close
or whether it could be the case that you
can find an exponential gap and maybe
one reason for why this was hard at
least why no separation was shown is
that almost all the known technique for
bounding communication complexity give
the same bound on information costs so
by most known techniques I mean
discrepancy methods
corruption bombs and stuff like that so
most of them were actually shown to be
subsumed by information costs so
basically if you wanna if you want to
separate the information communication
you need to give a lower bound on the
communication complexity but if you use
any of those methods the lower bound you
get is is the same for information costs
so it will not be strong enough to
separate so really need to come up with
a different technique if you want to
separate and this is what we do so this
is our result we give this first
separation between communication
complexity and information costs and
more formally we show that for every
parameter K you can construct a function
and a distribution such that the
information cost of the function is f k
but the communication is at least 2 to
the K ok so again we show that for every
K you can find a boolean explicit
boolean function such that in order to
compute f you the players will need to
exchange at least two to the case
communication bits but the actual
information you need to reveal in order
to compute F is only oh of K and this is
an exponential separation so x marks
result this is kind of tight you can
expect a gap larger than exponential so
we get to the larger scale possible and
kind of the bottom line is that this
shows that interactive protocols cannot
always be compressed to their
information content so it could be that
in some cases you can but not in general
yes
do you see anything about you are you
going to say I hopefully I'll show you
some the construction but yeah so mu is
is not a product distribution is a very
carefully designed distribution it
doesn't have full support hopefully
we'll get to see it it's explicit we I
can hopefully show you it in a few
minutes yes okay so this is a result
before showing you the construction I
wanna okay what is okay so just to
mention that in order to show the
separation we need to go give a lower
bound on the communication complexity
this is done by a new method which we
call relative discrepancy it has slight
connection to other discrepancy methods
we call it the relative discrepancy and
this is strong enough to separate
information okay so I want to show you
the construction but before let me give
one slide about a direct sum which is a
problem that is tightly connected to
interactive compression and actually
direct someone's the initial motivation
for defining information costs so all of
this field kind of stemmed from people
trying to solve the direct sound problem
okay so what is the direct some problem
again we we have our guys Alice and Bob
but now we give Alice M inputs x1 2 XM
and we give bob m inputs y 12 IM where
every pair of inputs is as before
sampled according to this distribution
view and the pairs are independent and
now the players want to computer to
evaluate F on every pair of inputs with
with high probability on everything in
on every copy ok so they want to compete
bunch of copies and the strong direct
some problem is the following we asked
whether competing m copy simultaneously
requires something like M times the
community
it needed to solve a single copy okay so
we're we have M copies we need we want
to sell to solve them simultaneously
this can take more than M times what it
costs to solve a single copy because you
can solve every one of them each one of
them separately but maybe you can do
something smarter right you have all the
inputs now maybe you can somehow combine
and get something that is more efficient
so the question is do you still have to
spend m times what it cost to to do a
single copy and what was shown by
marcona nope is that when M is is very
large the price per copy drops down to
the information costs if you do many
many copies the pair copy cost is only
the information not the communication
this is great right this also shows that
the rectum is equivalent to compression
because direct sum ask whether the price
per copy when you do many copies whether
it if it's the communication complexity
and this shows that it's the information
costs so if you know whether the
communication is the same as the
information you solve both questions ok
so the rectum is is exactly equivalent
to two full compression and therefore as
a corroboree for result we get that
strong direct sound doesn't hold so if
you want to so many copies and copies
together simultaneously you can use less
than M times what it costs to solve a
single copy so with this we just get for
free using their result using the result
of Mark and anup
ok questions about direct um so I don't
have a lot of time but I want to tell
you something about the cord the
construction okay so this is the example
separating information and communication
we call it the bursting noise game so I
need to I need to show you a function
and a distribution instead of showing
you function i'll give you a search
problem this you can convert it to an
actual boolean function we do it in the
paper but it's easier to show the search
problem and i want to show you the
actual distribution i'll show you a
simplified version but we think that
this should also work for technical
reason we had to do something more
complicated to get the proof to work
okay so what is the bursting noise game
to define it I'll need to have an
underlying tree this is a complete it
will be the complete binary tree will
group every 100k layers together and
call it a multi-layer so this is
multi-layer one multi-layer to multi
layer 3 and so on the depth of this tree
is going to be really huge it's going to
be 2 to the 4 to the K multi layers ok
so it's a huge tree a very deep tree and
now as we always do we will give a leaf
some input X and we'll give Bob another
input Y and each input will contain a
bit for every vertex in the tree so X
will be a bunch of bits and y will be
bunch of bits and for every vertex v XV
will be something either 0 or 1 and y v
will be either 0 or 1 they can be the
same they can be different but we give
the players one bit for every vertex in
the tree and just I want to know that
the size of the input here is is huge
triple exponential in this cave because
the depth is double exponential so the
number of vertices is triple exponential
so the parameters are not great in this
construction it's a good
though for me it's a very interesting
open problem to get better parameters it
will give better direct some results
okay and the ex the x and y will be
carefully correlated so we'll see how we
choose x and y okay so next I want to
tell you about the distribution you so
this is the way we select x and y it's
not a product distribution there is a
connection between x and y and we do the
phone too so to construct x and y we do
the following we first randomly select a
multi-layer so say this multi-layer I so
just a number between one and the depth
of the tree and then for every vertex in
this multi-layer we choose XV and widely
independently and at random okay for
every guy in here there are many
vertices in here for every for each of
them we select at random one bit and we
give it to Alice in another bit and we
give it to Bob independently and those
vertices will be called noisy vertices
for all other vertices so everything
that is outside multi-layer I so all the
guys in here and all the guys in here
for each of those vertices will choose x
and y to be the same so we'll select a
random run a bit and we'll give it to
both Alice and Bob and this will do for
every vertex and those vertices will be
called no noisy ok no noisy it's
basically the same bits for Alice and
Bob noisy means that the bitter
independent this is the distribution
it's not full support it's not a product
but this is the distribution ok next I
want to tell you what the function is it
won't be a function B it will be a
search problem but let me tell you the
goal so we know how to select this dose
x and y now I need to tell you what the
output on those x and y should be so
what what do the players need to do for
this we'll need the notion of typical
vertices ok so what are typical vertices
first we'll assume that the ice owns the
old layers so she
slayers 135 and so on Bob owns the even
layer so he owns layers 24 and so on
layers not multilayers just in one multi
layers we have many many layers so Alice
owns the owners Bob on the even layers
and now we say that the player so what
does it mean to own a vertex we say that
the player who all the vertex dictates
the correct child of this vertex so for
example if Alice owns V and the beach
she got for v XV 0 then left child is a
correction otherwise the right child is
the correct child looks like that Alice
owns the root so this is an example
Alice owns the roots cause it's in layer
1 and she owns the old layers she owns
the root if X before the route was 0
they need to go left and then they go
here now Bob owns this red red vertex if
v FY v is one for this vertex Oh Bob got
a 14 this vertex they need to go right
and so on this defined defines a path in
the tree ok so the player who owns it
who owns the vertex tell us where to go
next he decides where we should go next
and now i can define a typical red X so
suppose x and y are are fixed and I is
fixed everything is fixed a typical
verdicts is a vertex that is in multi
layer after multi-layer I so like all
the guys in here and the sub path in
multi-layer I that leads to V has at
least eighty percent correct children so
let's take this guy for example assume
that this is the layer just after
multi-layer I so let's take this guy I
will say that this guy is typical if the
following happens so let's look at the
path connecting the vertex to the root
there is a single unique path and now
I'm on looking at the part of the path
that intersects multi-layer I so I'm
only looking at this part of the path
and I'm asking whether it contains at
least eighty percent correct children so
whether at least eighty percent of the
time on this path I went to the right
direction okay XL might tell us what the
right direction is for every vertex I
want eighty percent of the time that
this path goes to the right direction to
the right child it doesn't have to do it
always but only on this sub half it does
need to do it eighty percent of the time
okay so this is a definition of a
typical vertex and this is just a remark
typical vertices are arranged in sub
trees it looks like this if this guy is
typical than everything in its sub tree
is typical if you take someone in here
then you look at the path connecting it
to the root this supper we know that
contains at least eighty percent correct
children so everything in here and
everything is here is also typical this
is not that important for us this is the
picture now I can tell you where the
function is or what is the what is the
search problem so the search problem is
the following the goal the player is to
find an out
it's the same typical if so what they
need to do they're getting x and y they
need to give us some some leaf in here
whatever they want this is just a search
problem not a function I'm saying that
we can actually convert it to a function
but this is the task so I think I'm
overtime I'll take one more minute just
to tell you why it makes sense but this
is this is the task that they need to
solve give us any typical leaf in here
whatever you want as long as it's the
same TT college okay so why is this
construction making sense I want to
claim that the communication complexity
should be high so the actual proof for
that is is pretty involved it was
simplified recently by an open Macklin
but I want to tell you like some
intuition of why I should believe that
that their communication is at least 2
to the K so this is a sanity check first
note that you cannot try if you try to
guess a leaf at random and claim the
data typically if this won't work
because typically for very rare if you
just sample a live here with probability
less than 2 to the minus K it's going to
be typical because the random leaf will
go fifty percent to the right direction
and we're asking for eighty percent so
typical reliefs are pretty rare you
can't expect to do that the other
problem is that the players can't find I
and I is really the key so if the
players knew I am claiming that they'll
be able to solve the game very easily so
if you know I you can start from this
point and just communicate your way on
this multi layer and this is enough you
take everything in the sub tree so
knowing guy is the key if you know I you
can only communicate multi-layer I the
vertices on multi-layer I and you're
done and we're not telling them what I
is but they can use a binary search to
find I and this will take log of see
bits say is the depth of the tree and
this is kind of the reason why we had to
set
to be so high to be double exponential
because we need locks it to be at least
2 to the K but basically if you don't
know what this I is then you really
don't know where to give information
right you can't possibly give
information on all the multi layers
there too many of them so either kind of
either you find this I which is hard
then if you don't know the size you need
to give information all over and this is
too much so of course this is a very
delicate argument but this is hopefully
you believe me that the communication
should be at least 2 to the K okay so
i'll stop here i'm over time but the
other thing that i didn't show you okay
i didn't show you the proof but i didn't
show you why the information cost is low
but there is a very simple protocol with
low information costs and this is our
example or simplified version of our
example this is it for me why did you
call typical
yeah i got this question a lot i don't
have okay if you see that if ya in our
minds it's typical if you see the
low-information cost protocol you see
that it's typical if you do the right
thing its kind of the typical vertex you
get to but yeah i'm not claiming that
this is a smart chorizo furniture if you
have product distributions that is the
stronger at direct some whole food ah
not so not strong but close to strongly
know how to compress to the information
costs x log the communication complexity
so if you know how to compress all the
way down to the information cause then
you get a strong direct um but there is
a log CC term there so you don't know it
all the way like you don't know strong
but you know something close yes this
result also leaves the the it's still
possible that you can compress
everything to i lobe lobe CC yeah we do
we're not answering this